uh good evening members and officers
i believe we have any public here
tonight
um welcome to the cabinet meeting on the
18th of november
fire alarm procedures if
the fire alarm is activated vacate the
offices via the stairs please do not use
the lifts assembling holy square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber
please switch off or
switch off or turn to silent your mobile
phones and do not make or receive calls
whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
as there are no members of the public um
i assume there's no filming
the following members have asked to
speak under council procedure rule 20.1
item 4 councillor king item 5 councillor
everett item 8 councillor yates
item 9 councillor yates item 10
councillors austin alban ghana and yates
i have received apologies from
councillor bob bayford and councillor
pugh
does anyone have any interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
item three minutes of previous meeting
to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet meeting held on the 23rd of
september 2021 the copy is attached to
the agenda pack i propose that we
approve the minutes do i have a seconder
councillor cup
do members agree
item 4 events policy and suitability of
events to introduce councillor cup
thank you very much chair um the events
policy was introduced in 2016 to provide
guidance to support to event organizers
while identifying the council's
processes
since then a review has been undertaken
of this policy and the event process to
ensure tdc are operating in the most
efficient way for both tdc and event
organizers
the events policy terms and conditions
and suitability of events documents have
been designed to streamline the process
and help organizers find information
quickly
tdc wants to ensure that the process is
clear and easy to understand to
encourage people to organize events in
the thana area
there are six main changes to the new
documents
number one organizers sorry there are
five main changes to the new documents
number one five
organizers are now required to read and
sign the policy showing they understand
all tdc terms and conditions
organizers are asked to think about co2
emissions and how they can be reduced
update to fees and charges to ensure a
fair charging scale for different size
events
the introduction of a suitability of
events document which outlines how the
council makes the decision on events and
lastly the inclusion of brand promotions
on tdc land to go through the events
process
events contribute to the local economy
in thanet district
there are sorry there have been over 230
events in thanet over the last few years
with a reduction due to the pandemic
this is predicted to increase in 2022
due to the recovering from the cover 19
pandemic which created the perfect
opportunity to introduce a policy that
is easy to understand along with a clear
charging framework
the policy outlines the importance of
safety identifying that events need to
be covered 19 compliant and that
organizers need to be thinking about
reducing carbon emissions in line with
the climate emergency called into a in
called by tdc in 2019
the new policy and supporting documents
will be supported in the introduction of
a new administration system that was
recommended by a number of kent councils
and will ensure a better customer
experience
i propose that cabinet agree option 3.1
of the report which is a to adopt the
events policy to include the suitability
of events document and new fees and
charges and that we formally agree that
tdc liaise with town councils and
margate trustees informing them of
events happening locally thank you chair
thank you um councillor cop has moved do
i have a seconder
councillor jill bayford
councillor
helen keane to speak uh under 20.1
thank you heather keane but yeah
okay thank you um yeah i mean there's a
lot to commend the report and
particularly clarifying um
and simplifying the process because it
used to be particularly difficult for
smaller events and i think the
process now is much more streamlined for
them but there are two points that i
would like to raise and the first one is
there is a lack of clarity in the
document still about the beaches
and whether they're included or not or
only out of season because they're
certainly all included in the table of
event spaces and i just think that needs
tightening up so it really is clear from
the beginning if we are using beaches
when we are using them and secondly
obviously it's very disappointing there
were only 10 responses in feedback um
that you got from people that had held
events in the past
and as there's going to be a debrief
after events can that information be
collated to form
better information in future about
what's working or not with this policy
thank you
thank you and we'd like to respond
please counselor
thank you uh councillor keane
on the beaches i'll i'll pass over
depending on that in just a second but
regarding to this responses and the
debrief around events um yeah i think
that that is definitely um
an idea to have and something that
should take place to ensure that any
events that are going on
we can learn from and improve on um or
even
see what comments that are positive from
how we've been holding events um so yes
i i think that is definitely a very good
suggestion
thank you so yes in terms of the beaches
we have looked at that
funnily enough this evening um because
we are aware that there was a problem in
the report um in terms of two options so
the beaches side of things is um that we
will not be looking to have new
um events on beaches
during the summer time however we will
look at each individual event on an
individual basis and the reasoning
behind this is we are getting more and
more
calls every year to have big 20 30 000
person events on margate main stands
particularly um as well as places like
jos bay and we just don't have the
capacity during the summer to hold
events like that so it's making sure
that what events are being put on are in
line with the area and so that's the
situation with beaches this there won't
be a whole summer ban um as we may have
kind of put in the policy and so that's
not not technically correct and we'll
make that change before we publish it
so you're happy to make those amendments
um
do members agree their recommendations
agree
[Applause]
item five is the procurement of housing
services service contracts to introduce
councillor jill baffert
thank you chair
the council is committed to improving
the standard of homes across the
district including the homes that it
owns and manages
we are also committed to working with
our tenants and leaseholders to deliver
this commitment
the re-tendering of our cleaning
contract which
um
have i got the right one
yes sorry
which provides the regular cleaning of
entrances bin areas and internal
communal areas of all our councils
residential blocks of flats provides an
opportunity to review the service
provided and to work with our tenants
and leaseholders to select a suitable
contractor for the coming two to four
years
budget provision is already in place to
support this procurement
since transition of the service to the
council from east kent housing the
council has provided twice nightly
security patrol service in each of our
six tower blocks
this was initial an interim measure to
assist in managing fire safety in these
blocks
but have proved extremely effective at
identifying and responding to a range of
issues
including rubbish and other items left
in communal areas noise and anti-social
behaviour
blocked rubbish chutes and activators of
firearms systems
the patrols
record and report all issues through to
the council's housing management
officers so that any follow-up actions
need to be needed can be arranged
it's therefore proposed to procure this
service on a longer term basis
budget provision is already in place to
support this service
in addition the council is currently
providing 24 interim 24-hour interim
waking watch services in five of its
tower blocks which are fitted with the
external wall insulation
the purpose of the waking watch service
is to assist with managing fire risk
within these buildings
ensure that the alarm is erased
immediately the inventive fire and
assist with evacuation
these blocks are due to have upgrades to
the alarm systems and the waking watch
services will be required until these
alarm upgrades are completed
the council is working closely with kent
fire and rescue in relation to fire
safety we have already jointly tested
the waking watch service procedures in
relation to our evacuation
the inclusion of this service
within the procurement is subject to the
approval of the necessary budget by the
full council
i move the recommendations set out in
the report
thank you councillor bayford do i have a
secondary
councillor saunders
speaking under 20.1 councillor everett
yes thank you leader um unlikely as it
may seem on councillor whitehead this
evening
unfortunately she's not very well so she
sent her apologies she couldn't be here
to speak herself um i don't have
anything very complicated to say um
councillor whitehead um did tell me
however that um
when this was discussed earlier i think
well during the labour administration
there was some idea of
um weighting the contract to wall
towards local suppliers to like towards
local businesses and i noticed that the
report
doesn't refer to that it does talk about
the more economically advantageous
submission although it talks about
quality and cost analysis so i just
wondered how far we're going to be able
to take into account
where these businesses are based because
obviously the people who are going to do
the work are going to have to be fairly
local because they'll have to be here
so it would be nice to support local
businesses if we can if any thought's
been given to that
i will say um you know i do have an
interest in this as a newington council
in particular because um stan occult is
in my ward
and obviously it's absolutely essential
that we have this waking watch service
and i'm sure we would all
put the safety of our tenants
as our absolute number one priority
i just wondered in terms of the cost of
this because it is a lot of money
um
obviously the budget's got to be
approved but i mean ultimately this does
fall on
our
council tenants as a whole through the
hra
and is there any thought that we can
recover any money for this waking watch
service from the government i know the
cap i know this discussion about the
capital financing of the improvements to
the buildings
um but are our poorest residents not
just in the um in the tower blocks but
our you know the people who live in our
social housing across the district and
they're not all poor but a lot of them
will be more more deprived
um
are they paying the price for this um
because it has come out the hra and are
we trying to recover it from government
thank you
thank you um don't come back
back on that joel thank you uh thank you
leader and thank you uh councillor
everett um i think that uh bob porter
will be better informed than i to answer
this question it's a very interesting
one thank you thank you bob
thank you counselor um so two things
firstly um
in terms of local procurement um yes we
we support the use of local contractors
wherever possible so
we're more than happy to explore with
our procurement team you know how how we
can encourage submissions from local
contractors in that process
in terms of funding you're absolutely
right the funding is coming from the
housing revenue account business plan um
funded by tenants and leaseholders we
have explored with government whether
there was potential to bid to support
that service and so far there hasn't
been an opportunity to bid for any
funding but if there is one that comes
up we would certainly be looking to take
advantage of that
thank you
also at cabinet we did discuss um
for a long term plan whether or not we
would actually
want to take on the cleaning
ourselves within the within the council
under our overall banner which would
obviously
save costs and also provide an income if
you like reversing come back into the
council so it was discussed um
we didn't feel that um
that we had enough lead time to to
actually put it in place but um it was
discussed and it is planned to have a
close look at that and cost benefits
for the future
so
do members agree the
recommendations of in the
item agreed
so item six is procurement of works at
church fields again to introduce
councillor jill bayford
thank you chair
this project is the demolition of
existing concrete bin stores and
canopies at the church fields flats and
and for the provision of 35 off street
parking bays for residents
the bin stores and canopies are past the
end of their useful life and have been
boarded and boarded up and unused for a
number of years
in preparation for this project the
council has consulted with the tenants
and leaseholders of these blocks who
expressed a preference for the proposed
project
the funding for this project is already
within the council's approved housing
resident account programme
i'll move the recommendations set out in
the report
thank you do i have a seconder
councillor george cup
there's no one asked to speak under this
so
i
propose that
members agree to the recommendations
great
so item seven mid-year review 2021-22
treasury management and annual
investment strategy to introduce
councillor david saunders thank you
leader
i'm pleased to report that the council
has operated within all of the boring
and investment lines set out
by our strategy for this year this
report shows within 4.2 and 4.3 which
are on pages 85 and 86 that our capital
spending was approximately 5 million at
the mid-year point
this within our revised capital budget
of 31 million but is well below our
expectations to where we would expect to
be at this point in the year
more detail is provided in the budget
monitoring report which is agenda item
eight of this evening's agenda our
revised capital budget for the year has
increased by about nine million compared
to the original but the majority of this
additional spending will be funded from
grants with only a modest increase in
borrowing
we currently have approximately 20
million of external borrowing no new
external borrowing was undertaken during
the first half of this financial year
but we have repaid 4 million of maturing
debt using our investment balances so
far
boring may be undertaken during the
second half of this financial year and
options will be reviewed in line with
market conditions
finally i propose an update to our
treasury management strategy to reflect
the delay in the implementation of the
new accounting standards for the leasing
of assets i'm assured that this
i'm sure that making this change ensures
our limits are adjusted to an
appropriate level
leader i move the recommendations
thank you
accounts look up
um do members agree
agree
item eight budget monitoring 2021 22
report number two to introduce
councillor david saunders
thank you
this report is the second budget
monitoring report for 2122 we're only
with an indicative 1.96 million general
fund overspend which is again largely
due to the ongoing impact of covid
the report assumes the use of government
funding of 1 million pounds leaving and
net overspend forecast of 0.96 million
to be funded from reserves that were set
aside last year specifically for this
purpose
this report also identifies
the latest general fund capital program
forecast for 2122
the latest housing revenue account
position
the need for cabinet to recommend to
council the decision to provide a
supplementary budget for legal costs
associated with private sector housing
the need for cabinet to agree the latest
position
for the gf capital programme including
the need for violence to realign
the need for cabinet to recommend to
council the decision to approve
supplementary capital budgets pertaining
to covid responses
ramsgate harbour rams gate port
homelessness and ellington park the need
for cabinet to recommend to council the
decision to approve a supplementary
budget of 896 000 pounds for
for the housing revenue account to cover
the cost of the waking watch service at
five tower blocks this be being until
such time as a new fire alarm sounders
can be installed
thank you
do you have a seconder
count
canceled your beaufort
speaking under 20.1 councillor yates
uh thank you leader uh just one comment
and two questions um firstly
um i think speak for many of us when say
we're we're very disappointed that the
decarbonization of the kent innovation
center um has been uh that project's no
longer viable
um
but from reading it does look like the
government sets incredibly tight uh
schedule when it comes to spending this
money um
and the consultants obviously uh
have it seems to have
potentially had some issues there
as well as inflationary pressures and
the cost of materials so just want to
make that point that that's incredibly
disappointing i think if there any new
opportunities that we can
insulate some of our buildings then we'd
go for that uh
give that our full support um so it's on
to two questions firstly on to your
leisure
um there's a mention of a 160k
um overspend in regard to your ledger
now there was a i believe a mention of a
loan agreement being set up previously
so i just want to ask um
what the situation is with that loan
agreement uh doubly
was being worked on and the second
question is
um
the 750k capital
programme in regarding public the public
toilet refurbishment so it doesn't look
like any of that money's been spent and
that was predicated on the toilets being
um sold some of the toilets being sold i
believe but now the tdc has taken back
the margate harbor arm and we are seeing
increased income from that is there any
opportunity to use similar income to
fund
capital improvements but on toilets
within thamet thanks
thank you councillor saunders um firstly
can i say that we're all disappointed
with regards to the
events um
where we were looking to improve
our insulation etcetera you're
absolutely right
the
grant money that was offered did come
with conditions and time restraints
um you're absolutely right that the
consultant given market forces
got
the figures
wrong and i think anyone that's
been involved with any building works
will know that materials in short supply
and the popularity of heatsink boilers
etcetera
has meant that we're now in a situation
where it's supply and demand and we
simply run out of
budget and time on that issue but we're
extremely disappointed and obviously
we'll be looking for other areas where
we can make significant improvements
with regards if i can move on to the
toilets you're absolutely right with
regards to toilets and my colleague on
my right is currently working on a
toilet strategy and i'm waiting for him
to come forward with the figures
involved with that toilet strategy so
that we can look at it within within our
budget
to see where we come from and i've got
the other questions sorry
oh your leisure um
the loan is still in place but um i
don't know if
chris bundle behind me can uh give us an
update with regards to the exact
position of where we are with your
leisure
certainly counselor thank you thank you
for the question council yates um just
for clarification the 160 000 pound
shortfalls because of unachievable
previous prior
savings that were agreed
conversations are ongoing with your
leisure in terms of the amount of
support that's needed to provide to keep
them
stable and operating and all other news
are being explored at the moment
thank you do cabinet agree with the
recommendation
agreed
so item nine
fees and charges 22 23
back to you councillors saunders
thank you
an initial review of the fees and
charges has now been completed as part
of the 2022-23 budget setting process
this has included the review of the
proposed fees and charges by the cabinet
advisory group and the recommendations
are detailed in the report for cabinets
consideration
key changes
have been detailed within the agenda
pack in 1.4
the review of fees and charges commenced
in the early summer and proposed fees
and charges were based on a broad 2
percent increase
however as the fees and charges setting
process developed it has become apparent
that inflation is significantly higher
than our two percent baseline that was
applied for next year
only yesterday the consumer price index
for october
was announced at 4.2 percent the highest
rate for a decade and it is forecast to
peak close to 5 over the coming months
the car the council is not immune to
these inflationary pressures pressures
rather as we too face increasing energy
and fuel bills as such it is important
that we are able to set our prices in
line with an increasing cost base but
also balancing this against market
conditions and the ability of our
customers to pay consequently i propose
a revisit of our fees and charges
assumptions
for next year and that we apply a three
percent increase instead of the two
percent that you'll find within the
paperwork you're looking at this evening
subject to the approval by cabinet
colleagues the fees and charges schedule
will be updated to reflect this and be
presented to council for approval on
this basis
i move the recommendations
thank you do i have a second
councillor club
speaking under 20.1 councillor yates
thank you leader um
apologies so once again one comment two
questions um first comments just about
the um pilot scheme for the parking
charges for electric vehicles fully
support that and i think um that's a
really good move
um as we go forwards um so onto the
first question
this is just about um
the 55 pounds um which is mentioned um
for green waste now
um
correct me if i'm wrong but i think in
the actual excel spreadsheet it's 54
pounds um
and can you just confirm
the price increase has moved from is it
53 pounds to 54 pounds so
i'm just wondering whether
this was meant to be on the front page
of report and what
could have been
intended to be on front page of the port
is actually the bulky waste collections
which has gone up from 26 pounds to 30
pounds which is a 15 increase
but
i don't know if i'm wrong there but if
you can
clarify that so that's the first
question the second one is just about
the
three percent increase in fees and
charges so
i think if it wasn't for the 691k budget
gap
um
uh then labor would not be in agreement
with increasing the fees and charges but
considering the national uh picture um
and as i'll go on to on the next um
agenda item
um
local government's just not getting the
money it's needed and because we need to
fill in the 691k budget gap uh this
three percent increase will actually
reduce that so it means we'll have to
make less cuts
so although
we're not very happy about it we won't
oppose that three percent um
uh increase in fees and charges um
so yeah
thanks thank you um
yes i'd love to like to be able to say
that we could look at it positively and
remain with the two percent uh and one
must remember that the increase is not
across the ball there are
large slaves of fees and charges where
there's been no proposal of increases
whatsoever um the 54 pound to 55 pounds
if i recall rightly was
a decision of the cabinet advisory group
a recommendation and the bulky waste
i put my hand up
i proposed that increase having used the
bulky waste collection service in the
past and given that you can
have five
items
and or
25 bags of general rubbish removed for
the 26 pounds as it was previously i
thought that was a very very good deal
and i didn't see an increase from 26 to
30
being over the top in fact
when i looked at it i thought we could
go higher but i really want to promote
that because it does overcome fly
tipping etcetera and i think
you know
anyone with
any
sense
would look towards their neighbours and
say this is a damn good deal
if you've got a fridge or an old cooker
or a heavy item
i'll book it and you put it with mine
you just and the service is excellent i
have to say i've used it two times in
the last year
you put you put the bulky um items out
at the front of your property and
they're collected normally before seven
in the morning a superb service and for
30 pounds five items i think that's an
absolute bargain
thank you
have i answered all the questions
i believe so thank you
yes and i just like to add on that that
if you buy a new appliance then they
charge you 25 quid to take it away
so and they're making the profit out of
you by the new one so i would um
second uh councillor saunders comment
that it is um a good value for money
service so um and to be encouraged so
and i once again i once again apologize
for the increase but i think
you're absolutely right given our
financial situation needs must
thank you
so it's been proposed and seconded do
members agree
item 10 budget and medium term financial
strategy 22 2022-2026
to introduce councillor david saudis
i'd want my finger out on google
and lost my page thank you leader
this report gives context and explains
the approach to setting next year's
budget the financial projections in this
report come with a health warning they
are based on the best estimations of our
financial staff on the latest impact of
the budget announcements all of which
are subject to change
although early indications on funding
for the forthcoming year are positive
the full impact of the announcements
will not be known until settlement is
received in december and as a result the
report highlights the
the delicate financial situation for the
council
apart from government funding there are
inflationary pressures in the region of
1.1 million pounds each year which
cannot be covered by increases in
council tax and fees and charges alone
table 1 in paragraph 3 sets out the
overall picture it projects a budget gap
of 0.691 million in
2022-23 i would emphasize again that
these figures are rough projections and
i know i
i speak for the section 151 officer in
giving this caveat but it's clear that
we will need to start rethinking how we
deliver services over the medium term
section 9 of the report
identifies some options for further
explanation to help contribute to those
savings over the medium term and the
recommendations contained seek cabinet
support two
one approve the strategy two
provide direction on how to bridge the
budget gap three that cabinet commits to
the development of a long-term saving
plan that exceeds two million pounds to
help bridge the gap over the medium term
i recommend
the i rather i move the recommendations
thank you
thank you
and secondary
counselor cop
speaking under 20.1 i have councillor
austin alban garner and yates so council
austin first
thank you leader um can we thank first
of all the finance team for this report
which is depressing but um easy to
understand even for those of us who are
not finance people
and um
contains some some really uh useful
projections
at different levels of income uh the
first thing i would want to say is that
i do hope that
you leader will be making
representations via our mp into
government about the fact that we have
so little information that things keep
changing that reductions and reductions
keep happening in our income from
government because
as we've seen with the with the
decarbonisation project
it appears that more and more
restrictions are being placed on what we
can do even with money we've bid for and
that doesn't leave us or any other local
authority in a very comfortable place
um i wanted to start on income because
obviously there's been a focus on
savings here and i'm wondering
to what extent we can
expand our income in other ways for
example how much of counsellor cups
toilet strategy can we get southern
water to pay for it strikes me that we
should be getting southern water to pay
for all our public lavatories all around
the coast including building some new
ones and the maintenance we really need
to be looking to them for reparations
for what they've done and i know you've
been working hard on that leader
but i really would want to push on that
and i'd also want to look at how we can
generate more income via sponsorship
from local firms and so on four
different sorts of activities that we're
involved in
moving on to
spending um i am concerned obviously
staffing is is a major cost and we have
to look carefully at staffing but i am
worried about the deletion of some of
the
roles that we have found hard to fill
particularly in front line services like
waste and open spaces because that's
going to affect adversely the experience
of residents and we already
have difficulty and i know managers are
really struggling sometimes to cover
those services
and we had an extremely useful and
constructive couple of meetings of the
overview and scrutiny panels um coastal
waste working party recently one with
parish and town councils and one with
voluntary organizations and i wondered
to what extent cabinet was considering
looking at the ways that we work
with parish and town councils and with
our voluntary groups and whether there
might be some way of
helping to balance the budget by
arranging more
maintenance contracts with those
organizations
um i was worried about the fact that
we've got quite a lot of staffs off sick
in those areas as well and obviously we
have to make special arrangements um for
them if there are to be redundancies
because the last thing we want is any
other sort of legal case
and finally i wanted to uh looked at the
um
proposals of reorganization of the
senior leadership team and i wondered if
the senior leadership team had
considered a voluntary temporary salary
reduction many of us who have led
organizations through austerity have
found ourselves having to offer this
it is not desirable but on the other
hand it does help save money and it does
generate a feeling of we're all in it
together thank you leader
thank you you got to come back on that
council someday i'll come back on the
ones that i can i can't comment on the
senior team
what i can say is that when we're
preparing the budget we rely on the
budget holders
to come forward with their proposals
which we can challenge
but on the
question of
not filling
long-term vacancies
our advice from the budget holder was
that we can reorganize to cover that
shortfall
and obviously from a financial situation
once a budget holder comes and tells you
that then you
you accept it and you inbuild it into
into your figures etcetera
with regards to
the situation with parish councils and
town councils i can tell you that we are
already in discussion with regards to
a certain asset transfers etc and within
my colleagues
toilet strategy which we've yet to see
published
there is an indication and a very strong
indication that we will be looking for
partnership arrangements with both
parish and town councils and commercial
outlets as appropriate
um i think the only other one is the
senior which i really can't make any
comment chief executive on that one
have i covered all of the points thank
you yeah i think if the chief exec can
come and also cover the sickness levels
as well i think was raised thank you
thank you leader um yes uh first point
uh in respect of the point raised around
vacancies uh stroke deletion of roles um
i think obviously yes we are looking at
those vacant posts i think we're looking
at those that have been vacant for a
period of time and reassessing
those i think we're in a situation where
difficult decisions have to be made
and our preferences obviously which i'm
sure you'd understand that we'd rather
look at vacancies rather than make other
people redundant so that's why we're
exploring that but no final decisions
have been made about that at this point
um in respect of i wasn't quite sure i
understood the point about people being
off sick and redundancies um the two are
not related at all quite rightly they
shouldn't be so uh just to reassure you
i was thinking about the special
protection that people of sick have
absolutely absolutely and obviously in
respect of any restructures that we may
look at obviously we have now have our
in-house hr team and obviously we'd be
involving them and obviously we'd be
seeking their advice about about how we
approach any such such
issues but obviously that's not
something that's on our agenda at the
moment
um in respect of the senior management
team um i wouldn't be proposing that
just simply because we we often have
these conversations and i'm sure you
appreciate through employee council with
the with the unions this this does come
up from time to time and albeit i do
recognize
the principles around why people would
suggest it i think i also have to
balance that as head of paid service
against the fact that actually senior
officers work very hard when we've
previously assessed the market rate that
our senior officers have paid it's not
been comparable to other areas in fact
it's been lower and and i think we just
have to recognize that we need to retain
people
at a time uh when things are quite
challenging and i think that would be
quite a disincentive
if we started to go down that road cert
road so i won't be just being honest and
upfront with you i wouldn't be
recommending that thank you thank you
um council saunders coming back um yes i
don't believe i um i covered
the
item on
income
what i can tell you is that we
at
cabinet level have been looking at
innovative
areas that
we could perceive would
in time
generate additional income
but unfortunately
those areas do come with a risk and
whilst we've been preparing this budget
we've adopted about a budgetary prudence
attitude
but we will be looking at areas
where perhaps
we can look to get some guaranteed
income without the risks that
we've incurred in the past with with
such innovative ideas thank you
[Music]
and um i can come back on the southern
water um as you know that um
there was a an original payment by
southern water
which has been ring fenced to be used
for um
the benefit of the communities i'm still
working on the
the um the concept behind how that will
be spent
which we can
detail
very shortly but i've also
since the joss bay
event
asked for
other sums of money
and i'm just waiting to hear back on
that
so
needless to say i will push as hard as i
can
and
toilets would could obviously come into
into effect but um i think you know we
should really be looking more of a
strategy to to make it sustainable
rather than relying on southern what uh
i just
pray that we don't get any other
leakages so i don't really want to
be reliant on southern water bailing us
out for
for the shortfalls on our services but
um
needless to say if i do manage to
obtain some further funds for them then
they will be to the benefit of the
community
next to speak under 20.1 is councillor
auburn
thank you leader
yeah just to go back uh i also have
concerns over the um
over the loss of of jobs and the um
getting rid of posts
um are specifically
uh concerned in relation to the waste
services and i'm specifically further
concerned about the
we did
um through
the hard work of
mr waite
a year or so ago in getting uh through
the budget um ten environmental
operatives
five of which have been employed
and i'm hoping
uh
that the other five posts that weren't
filled
are not going to be got rid of
uh i and i i think it's extremely
important that they are retained
um and filled
and the reason i'm saying that is is
because in each of our
um
public consultations the response from
the public is in relation to waste
recycling keeping our streets clean
etcetera and the environmental
operatives
were put there enable us to
to uh
impact on the issues that are raised by
residents in specific areas that they
might be fly-typing or they could be
anything like that which we could react
to um so i'm extremely concerned
about that and i could not support that
and i'm sure my
labor group colleagues would not support
that we would not support the budget if
that if that happens
um and obviously i've also seen uh
in there that there is growth of 402 000
pound for waste
in in the report
so it does seem rather uh ridiculous if
this is the case that we get that we get
rid of five posts and yet we're putting
402 thousand pound in
um i know that's it's not as simple as
that i i understand that um but
that's how it looks
that's how it and that's how it looks to
the to the public
and um certainly uh chaired um
you know i i would certainly hope that
you would look at this and change your
mind in relation to these posts being
extinguished
and thank you ever so much thank you
cancer song do you want to come back um
yeah as i i would again
say and you probably know this from your
previous experience we do rely on the
budget holders to come forward with
their proposals and what you're talking
about
in
sitting in my seat is strategy rather
than budget
and
it's a strategy that's been prepared
and i have to accept it from the budget
holders
i agree i'm very disappointed that we've
had these vacancies for the period the
time that we have and haven't managed to
attract the people that we need
but
we'll see how it pans out but at the
moment the budget as it's presented and
all of the figures that we have
have been received
we've received them in good faith from
the budget holders and as i say
maybe the strategy needs to be looked at
but i'm sure
the figures that come out at the end of
the day i will insist that they're
unchanged irrespective of uh whether
there's any changes to the strategy
thank you
uh thank you chief executive wants to
come in
um yes if i may thank you uh thank you
leader just to to say um obviously
council auburn uh appreciate the points
that you are making and you're right
obviously there's a bit more context to
the detail and i think uh obviously we
take on board that maybe we need to look
at how we represent some of that if
indeed we go down that route as part of
the final budget decision
but as i say because these are proposals
at this stage principles which we are
seeking cabinet support from but also
just to remind people uh from a staffing
perspective obviously that's my remit as
head of paid service so ultimately i
make the decisions around what resources
we need
as an organisation to deliver the
services we have so clearly we are
looking for cabinet support around the
principles that we use in respect of the
budget of course that's absolutely right
but from the staffing perspective
clearly that's something i have to give
some consideration to in respect of
within the budget that we have available
how we best deliver the services thank
you
also speaking under 20.1 concert
councillor ghana
thank you thank you leader
um yeah as as has been mentioned by a
couple of people this is obviously a
worrying report for for all of us um and
especially for all residents of planet
um of the three scenarios that are
discussed in the report when even the
neutral one
uh sees us getting within just a million
pound of the minimum acceptable level of
reserves in the next three or four years
i think it's important that we
understand some of the risks
some that
that could um move us towards the
pessimistic scenario
which would see us diminish our reserves
to an unacceptable level um some of
these risks i couldn't find mentioned in
the report
and the first of these
relates to some of the matters
we've discussed quite in depth really
relating to the recent section 24 report
which highlighted potential costs
of 700 000 plus
as the cabinet member and a section 151
officer
been able to identify the additional
saving plan to address those further
cost pressures creating resolving the
grievance and whistleblade complaints
yet as as per one of the recommendations
in that report
and the second area of risk
which i didn't see mentioned much in the
report
relates to the finances is the port
has an assessment been done
on the added costs faced as a result of
the recent withdrawal of a
marine license application relating to
burst form 5 and the additional cost
these further delays will result in
thank you
um i suspect there'll be various that
need to come back on that but um if
you'd like to kick off well i was just
going to make uh i was just going to say
that
as
chairman of the idsc
and an individual that is waiting for
an interview
with the ipp i really can't comment on
your first question
and with regards to the port i think uh
count the leader or indeed the chief
executive are in a better position to
answer those i don't know if the
if chris wants to come back on the first
point but i i trust
the figures that have been given us so
far with regards to um your first point
um i think um
they are correct at this point in time
um and obviously they've been in build
can i just go back on on the free grids
and and as councillor yates will know
i tend to be a pessimist so the grid
that i was working out the table is
table two
and
losing sleep at times over that table
too and we've gone with the
positive one rather than the
well i consider to be over optimistic
one but um
i'm keeping everything crossed that we
can deliver
in all aspects of what we've prepared
and what we're proposing thank you
chief executive
thank you chair thank you council garner
for question
in terms of the risks as councillor
saunders set out um
within the different scenarios it sets
out the different factors that could be
varied that would potentially bring us
towards that most pessimistic scenario
um stuff that's been discussed at some
month this evening around inflation
rates um
our own income
our ability to generate income um but
fundamentally it's around uh reform of
the local government finance system and
something that's actually outside of our
control
and we'll be watching very carefully to
see what the government announces in
terms of reform they'll be forthcoming
as part of the
local government finance settlement that
we hope to receive early next month
in terms of the additional savings that
came out the section 24 report
excuse me within the main body of the
report um there's a section that sets
out
just under 3.1
talks around the overall
budget position that summarizes the gap
at 691
the right the bottom that table there is
a section for reserve movements and
you'll see a contribution reserves 180
000 pounds and that reflects the
recommendations have been made from
grant thornton in terms of finding
funding so the budget gap already
accommodates 180 000 contribution to
reserves over a four-year period that
would help to restore balances um back
to the level that were required to fund
those costs that have been provided for
okay okay um chief of stakes you want to
speak about the port
uh thank you leader uh yes in response
respect of the poor and the specific
references to births four five um just
to confirm what you already obviously
appreciate that the
council has withdrawn its submission to
the marine management organization for
licence with the intention of
resubmitting a new application in line
with the requirement to have an eia
the the current position is that the
project remains still within budget
there may be a small additional cost as
a result of having to resubmit but
obviously a lot of the work that was
submitted
as part of the original uh application
will be retained so we're obviously
minimizing any additional costs
associated with that but just to
reassure it is within budget i can't
tell you at this stage what that
additional cost would be but we have
already accounted for it but i'm happy
to find that figure and share with you
uh just to add that um i will be making
a
[Music]
a statement tomorrow regarding that just
to clear up the matter so that it can
put people's minds at rest so
outlining the position
um
next to speak under 20.1 is councillor
yates
thank you leader um so three questions
here so the first one's just about as
mentioned this um
table uh
the optimistic pessimistic neutral table
so just to highlight what i think is
pretty incredible really that
by 25 to 20 20 25 to 26 um in every
situation we're looking at a two million
pound
um budget gap um
so and this reiterates what other
councillors have said tonight which is
we we do need to be thinking about
income generation so
an idea
that has been
uh going around a long time but we still
support it is the idea of beach huts
so
whitstable
recently sold off their beach shots
which we would not agree with but they
went for 90 grand each and we i think
the cost of building it would be much
much lower than that so
i think like people mentioned the past
ramsgate is potential place for building
beach huts um
so that would be something we'd support
so
um
i guess the question is
can we consider income generation
um separately because
we can't just be talking about cuts um
second point's just around
the report and clause 3.7 because it's
it's mentioning two percent increase in
fees and charges but the separate report
we've just discussed is mentioning three
percent so just want some clarity on
that one
um and the last points just around uh
beach management plans so during the
pandemic labor um
kicked off the beach management plan and
we did that early in the season so the
the toilets were open our beaches and
portals were prepared for a large influx
early on in the season i think it was
march april time um
[Music]
and i think i've got concern
um it'd be good to get some clarity
about whether that beach management plan
can be introduced again this year um as
i believe we will well next year um as
we believe we will have a
again a large influx of people coming to
the beaches
uh earlier on in the year and
because i think if it doesn't if it
isn't introduced we could see chaos on
our beaches once again um and if it's
not going to be introduced then we
definitely need some clear comms early
on about that um so we've got a large
big question mark about whether beach
management plan
will be part of this budget going
forward thanks
so um would you like to
come back um council saunders on the i
think yeah i mean i've already uh thank
you
rob
i think i've already come back with the
income generation
ideas we have
discussed a number of ideas
and
we've also
looked at beach huts and exactly
what we could do with these shots
there's
difference of opinions with regards to
beach huts whether they
are going to be if you like basic
or luxury um and whether they whether we
are going to carry on with allowing
people
to pay for
a pitch or whether we want to look at a
long-term
solution of having permanently based
beach huts as they do in some seaside
resorts which will generate quite
considerable income
beach management plan
to be perfectly honest i'm not sure but
whether that's still in there and i
don't know whether
gavin can assure me
on that point
i do believe it's still still there
because we have had discussions on the
beach management plan and how it pans
out but i think we've got plans for a
dual role of some of our operatives but
perhaps
gavin can elaborate
yeah
gavin if you'd like to come back on that
yeah thank you actually officers are
reviewing uh the plan from last year
obviously lesson learned uh what we need
to consider is the the intention is to
bring the plan forward into next year
as you can appreciate and you sort of
indicate it is there's a resource issue
because lots of the activity was paid
for from government funding through conf
and and some of that
so we're just looking at different ways
of working but it is the intention that
we will be reviewing it also the psp as
well and the benefit of the pspo and i
know we've had some feedback in terms of
some of our activities enforcement
activities we could probably include in
the psb as well so we'll be reviewing
that and then also i know it's been
indicated that uh overview and scrutiny
there's a there's a group of there's a
group going to be reporting to other
human scrutiny i mean it's predominantly
with regards to beach litter management
but it will be reported into overview
and scrutiny and then they'll be
recommending uh some improvements
working on what we've done in the past
what we've done in the future also like
uh been speaking to local community
groups local businesses and also they're
going to be speaking to other local
district councils as well about how they
carry out that activity so we're the
intention is that we will have a beach
management plan for next year and
the resources to at least implement as
much as we can
i think uh the
two percent to three percent report to
come back on yeah once we get um the
site of the revised
fees and charges with the
increase in those areas that we would be
looking to increase then we'll
review our overall situation and then
build it into our final presentation to
council thank you
um and i'd just like to reassure members
that i spend most of my time trying to
think of ways to generate income and
inward investment it is my main
concentrate and uh priority um
uh maybe some of it um is a little bit
risky and uh so i have to balance that
off against what would uh be deemed to
be acceptable but i can assure you i
know that our assets our main asset is
18 miles of coastline and i really think
we
totally under utilize that as a revenue
stream so certainly um
a lot of thought will be going into that
and a lot of proposals that yes you're
quite right i think beach huts
or even
overnight stays
call it what you like
maybe not
airbnb but um c bet c b and b i i've
renamed it so um um i think we could
probably charge about 200 pounds a night
and get away with it so uh you're quite
right
um
whitstable i think they missed a trick
there to be honest but um rather be
making money out of our assets rather
than selling them off um i don't really
want to sell the crown jewels off before
until we really completely run out of
money so um no very much concentrating
on that and the cabinet are very much
behind that thought process we can't
keep cutting back
the um
the costs so we've got to we've got to
work out how to get some money in and
offer any suggestions coming forward on
that so if anyone anyone's got any ideas
members then
bring them forward no problem thank you
and if i could just add to that one of
the things that
we're looking at
is the word hut
um i think
that that in your mind's eye when you
say a beach hut you've got a certain
picture um so we're thinking more um you
know luxury pods
anyway um i don't think we've actually
uh
we've moved and secured it so do members
agree
well i believe that concludes the
business for tonight and i declare the
meeting closed charles and
the livestream will now end and thank
you members and officers for attending
and enjoy the rest of your evening thank
you
you